Make every get-together chill. This Memorial Day, get up to an extra $1,000 off select top brand appliances like LG. Plus, get free delivery at the Home Depot. Tackle pool towels and camp laundry with a large capacity washer. And host in style with the fridge serving craft ice, mini craft ice, cube ice, and crushed ice. Shop appliance savings now through June 3rd at the Home Depot. Offer valid May 14th through June 3rd, US only. Free delivery on appliance purchases of $998 or more.
Make every get-together chill. This Memorial Day, get up to an extra $1,000 off select top brand appliances like LG. Plus, get free delivery at the Home Depot. Tackle pool towels and camp laundry with a large capacity washer. And host in style with the fridge serving craft ice, mini craft ice, cube ice, and crushed ice. Shop appliance savings now through June 3rd at the Home Depot. Offer valid May 14th through June 3rd, US only. Free delivery on appliance purchases of $998 or more.|||让每次聚会都轻松惬意。今年阵亡将士纪念日，购买LG等指定顶级品牌家电，最高可享额外1000美元优惠。此外，在家得宝（Home Depot）购买还可享免费送货服务。用大容量洗衣机轻松清洗泳池毛巾和露营衣物。用能制作手作冰块、迷你手作冰块、方冰和碎冰的冰箱，尽显待客风范。即日起至6月3日，来家得宝选购家电优惠。优惠有效时间为5月14日至6月3日，仅限美国地区。购买家电满998美元即可享受免费送货。
See Store Online for details. How many articles have you read about the generation wars? From using phrases like OK Boomer to entitled millennials, how we talk about generations makes it sound like each group is pitted against the others. Now, as the oldest members of Gen Z enter the workforce, we are facing something we haven't seen before, the possibility of five generations in the same workplace. from the silent generation to baby boomers to gen X to millennials all the way to Gen Z. It's no surprise that mismatched generational habits and expectations can cause tension and
See Store Online for details. How many articles have you read about the generation wars? From using phrases like OK Boomer to entitled millennials, how we talk about generations makes it sound like each group is pitted against the others. Now, as the oldest members of Gen Z enter the workforce, we are facing something we haven't seen before, the possibility of five generations in the same workplace. from the silent generation to baby boomers to gen X to millennials all the way to Gen Z. It's no surprise that mismatched generational habits and expectations can cause tension and|||详情请参阅线上店铺。你读过多少关于代际战争的文章？从使用“好吧，婴儿潮一代”这样的短语到“享有特权的千禧一代”，我们谈论代际的方式听起来就像每个群体都在与其他群体对立。如今，随着Z世代中最年长的一员进入职场，我们正面临着前所未有的情况——同一个职场中可能同时存在五代人。从沉默的一代、婴儿潮一代、X世代、千禧一代，一直到Z世代。毫不奇怪，代际之间不匹配的习惯和期望可能会导致紧张和
misunderstandings in the workplace. But researchers who study organizational behavior say that understanding the differences between and among generations and seeing them as strengths rather than as weaknesses can help organizations and individuals thrive. So how can we move past stereotypes about Gen X, slackers, entitled millennials, and change-resistant boomers to understand which generational differences are real and which aren't? How much do generations matter to people's identity? Are generations always a useful way to categorize people?
misunderstandings in the workplace. But researchers who study organizational behavior say that understanding the differences between and among generations and seeing them as strengths rather than as weaknesses can help organizations and individuals thrive. So how can we move past stereotypes about Gen X, slackers, entitled millennials, and change-resistant boomers to understand which generational differences are real and which aren't? How much do generations matter to people's identity? Are generations always a useful way to categorize people?|||职场中的误解。但研究组织行为的研究人员表示，理解代际之间以及代际内部的差异，并将其视为优势而非劣势，可以帮助组织和个人蓬勃发展。那么，我们如何才能抛开对X世代、摸鱼者、享有特权的千禧一代以及抗拒变革的婴儿潮一代的刻板印象，去理解哪些代际差异是真实的，哪些不是？代际对人们的认同有多大重要性？代际总是对人进行分类的有用方式吗？
On a practical level, how can you learn to communicate well with much younger or much much older colleagues. And what should organizations be doing to help workers of all ages understand and learn from each other? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Megan Gerhardt, a professor of management and leadership at the Farmer School of Business at Miami University, where she studies how organizations can benefit from generational diversity in the workplace. She's the author of many academic studies and of the book Gen Intelligence, a revolutionary approach to leading an intergenerational
On a practical level, how can you learn to communicate well with much younger or much much older colleagues. And what should organizations be doing to help workers of all ages understand and learn from each other? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Megan Gerhardt, a professor of management and leadership at the Farmer School of Business at Miami University, where she studies how organizations can benefit from generational diversity in the workplace. She's the author of many academic studies and of the book Gen Intelligence, a revolutionary approach to leading an intergenerational|||在实际层面，你如何学会与年轻得多或年长得多的同事进行良好的沟通？组织又该做些什么来帮助所有年龄段的员工互相理解和学习？欢迎收听《心理学言论》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，主要探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是迈阿密大学（Miami University）法默商学院（Farmer School of Business）的管理与领导力教授梅根·格哈特（Megan Gerhardt）博士，她在那里研究组织如何从职场中的代际多样性中受益。她撰写了许多学术研究，并著有《代际智慧》（Gen Intelligence）一书，这是一本领导跨代际团队的革命性方法指南。
workforce. Her work has been featured in media outlets including Harvard Business Review, the Washington Post, and CNN, among others. Dr. Gerhardt, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me, Kim. I called out a few stereotypes in my introduction, the Gen X Slacker, the entitled millennial, for example. So let's start there. Where do these stereotypes come from, and how accurate are they? I think in most cases, any stereotype is a shortcut we take to decision making. It is, I think, the lazy way of trying to understand things that are difficult and complicated. There's roots in every stereotype or label we hear that come from places that are actually really interesting and make a lot of sense. So for example, I'll start with my own generation,
workforce. Her work has been featured in media outlets including Harvard Business Review, the Washington Post, and CNN, among others. Dr. Gerhardt, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me, Kim. I called out a few stereotypes in my introduction, the Gen X Slacker, the entitled millennial, for example. So let's start there. Where do these stereotypes come from, and how accurate are they? I think in most cases, any stereotype is a shortcut we take to decision making. It is, I think, the lazy way of trying to understand things that are difficult and complicated. There's roots in every stereotype or label we hear that come from places that are actually really interesting and make a lot of sense. So for example, I'll start with my own generation,|||她的工作曾被《哈佛商业评论》、《华盛顿邮报》和CNN等媒体报道。格哈特博士，非常感谢您今天能来。谢谢你邀请我，金。我在介绍中提到了一些刻板印象，例如X世代的摸鱼者、享有特权的千禧一代。那么我们从这里开始。这些刻板印象从何而来？它们的准确性如何？我认为在大多数情况下，任何刻板印象都是我们在做决定时采取的捷径。我认为，这是试图理解困难和复杂事物的一种偷懒方式。我们听到的每一个刻板印象或标签都有其根源，这些根源实际上非常有趣且合乎情理。例如，我从我自己的这一代开始，
the Slack or Gen Xers. The roots of that are actually quite interesting if you think about the fact that Gen X as a generation, not by the person I always like to say, but the norm of Gen X was that we grew up valuing free time and autonomy and actually were the least supervised generation ever. So I always like to say, you can look at statistics on this. We had the highest level dual career families, single parent families of all time before or since during Gen X's childhood, which meant a lot of freedom and autonomy growing up, something that we were hesitant as a generation to maybe give up when we started our careers, wanted more balance, wanted more flexibility, wanted to hold onto that independence through the lens of the baby boomer
the Slack or Gen Xers. The roots of that are actually quite interesting if you think about the fact that Gen X as a generation, not by the person I always like to say, but the norm of Gen X was that we grew up valuing free time and autonomy and actually were the least supervised generation ever. So I always like to say, you can look at statistics on this. We had the highest level dual career families, single parent families of all time before or since during Gen X's childhood, which meant a lot of freedom and autonomy growing up, something that we were hesitant as a generation to maybe give up when we started our careers, wanted more balance, wanted more flexibility, wanted to hold onto that independence through the lens of the baby boomer|||也就是摸鱼的X世代。如果你考虑到这样一个事实，它的根源其实相当有趣：作为一个世代的X世代——我总是喜欢说，不是指某个人，而是X世代的常态——我们是在重视自由时间和自主性的环境中长大的，实际上也是有史以来受到监督最少的一代。所以我总是喜欢说，你可以看看相关的统计数据。在X世代的童年时期，我们拥有有史以来最高水平的双职工家庭和单亲家庭（无论是在此之前还是之后），这意味着在成长过程中享有极大的自由和自主权。在我们开始职业生涯时，作为一代人，我们可能有些犹豫是否要放弃这种自由，我们想要更多的平衡，想要更多的灵活性，想要通过婴儿潮一代的视角来保持这种独立性……
generation, who as a norm, again, I don't ever want to characterize a whole generation as being a certain way. We're always wrong when we do that and my work pushes back against that pretty strongly. But the norm for baby boomers was success comes from nose to the grindstone, working very hard, harnessing that intense work ethic to get to the top and make the most of yourself and make the most opportunities you could for your family that maybe your parents weren't able to make for you. So through the lens of a baby boomer who was hiring JetEx, them saying they wanted to have balance or independence or time for themselves seems like you're being a slacker. That's not the norm that they embraced and therefore it didn't make sense. And we see that
generation, who as a norm, again, I don't ever want to characterize a whole generation as being a certain way. We're always wrong when we do that and my work pushes back against that pretty strongly. But the norm for baby boomers was success comes from nose to the grindstone, working very hard, harnessing that intense work ethic to get to the top and make the most of yourself and make the most opportunities you could for your family that maybe your parents weren't able to make for you. So through the lens of a baby boomer who was hiring JetEx, them saying they wanted to have balance or independence or time for themselves seems like you're being a slacker. That's not the norm that they embraced and therefore it didn't make sense. And we see that|||作为一个常态，婴儿潮一代——再次声明，我绝不想把整整一代人定性为某种特定样子。当我们这样做时，总是会出错，我的工作对这种做法进行了相当强烈的反对。但婴儿潮一代的常态是：成功来自于埋头苦干、非常努力的工作，利用这种强烈的职业道德登上顶峰，充分发挥自我价值，并为你的家庭创造尽可能多的机会，而这些机会或许你的父母当年没能为你创造。因此，在招聘X世代的婴儿潮一代看来，他们说想要平衡、独立或属于自己的时间，就好像你在偷懒一样。这不是他们所拥有的常态，因此这在他们看来毫无意义。我们看到
came with every generation, that there's a different set of norms that have developed based on really rational, important reasons. But when we judge those through our own norms, we often view them as wrong. Why do you think we're so quick to stereotype people who are either older or younger than we are. It's rooted in the similarity effect. So we tend to feel more comfortable with people we perceive, quote, to be like us. There's lots of great research on that. And anything that is different is challenging. It requires, I think, really more thought. It requires more time. And we often don't have the opportunity, particularly in our workplaces, in our organizations, to really get to know someone who is substantially older or younger.
came with every generation, that there's a different set of norms that have developed based on really rational, important reasons. But when we judge those through our own norms, we often view them as wrong. Why do you think we're so quick to stereotype people who are either older or younger than we are. It's rooted in the similarity effect. So we tend to feel more comfortable with people we perceive, quote, to be like us. There's lots of great research on that. And anything that is different is challenging. It requires, I think, really more thought. It requires more time. And we often don't have the opportunity, particularly in our workplaces, in our organizations, to really get to know someone who is substantially older or younger.|||每一代人都是如此，基于非常理性、重要的原因，发展出了一套不同的常态。但当我们用我们自己的常态去评判这些时，我们往往会认为它们是错误的。你认为为什么我们这么快就会对比我们年长或年轻的人产生刻板印象？这植根于相似性效应。因此，对于我们认为“像我们”的人，我们往往会感到更舒适。有很多关于这方面的优秀研究。任何不同的东西都是具有挑战性的。我认为，这确实需要更多的思考。这需要更多的时间。而且我们经常没有机会，尤其是在我们的职场、我们的组织中，去真正了解一个明显比我们年长或年轻的人。
So we tend to enter into organizations with people in our similar age cohort who start their careers at a similar time. And so unless a company is really proactive in creating teams that go across different ages, generations, career stages, we may not know well people outside of our own family that are substantially older or younger. And when that's the case, we don't have a personal relationship or interaction to count on, we tend to lean into those shortcuts of broad brush, well, all baby boomers are this way, or all Gen Z is that way, which is never correct,
So we tend to enter into organizations with people in our similar age cohort who start their careers at a similar time. And so unless a company is really proactive in creating teams that go across different ages, generations, career stages, we may not know well people outside of our own family that are substantially older or younger. And when that's the case, we don't have a personal relationship or interaction to count on, we tend to lean into those shortcuts of broad brush, well, all baby boomers are this way, or all Gen Z is that way, which is never correct,|||因此，我们倾向于与年龄相仿、在相近时间开始职业生涯的人一起加入组织。因此，除非一家公司非常积极地创建跨越不同年龄、代际和职业阶段的团队，否则我们可能不会真正了解自己家庭之外、明显比自己年长或年轻的人。在这种情况下，我们没有可以依赖的个人关系或互动，我们往往会倾向于采用那种“一刀切”的捷径，比如“嗯，所有婴儿潮一代都是这样的”或者“所有Z世代都是那样的”，这从来都是不正确的，
but it's easy. And that's where those really harmful stereotypes and biases and prejudice come in in both directions. It's not a one-directional issue. It's a multi-generational issue, unfortunately. Well, let's talk about the workplace. What are some of the best? benefits that come from having a multi-generational workplace. So what's fascinating and what really drives my work is that what we're talking about is a type of diversity of thought, perspective, and experience. So we know a lot about the power and benefit of all kinds of diversity in the workplace. But for some reason, best practices around that are very rarely applied to age or generation.
but it's easy. And that's where those really harmful stereotypes and biases and prejudice come in in both directions. It's not a one-directional issue. It's a multi-generational issue, unfortunately. Well, let's talk about the workplace. What are some of the best? benefits that come from having a multi-generational workplace. So what's fascinating and what really drives my work is that what we're talking about is a type of diversity of thought, perspective, and experience. So we know a lot about the power and benefit of all kinds of diversity in the workplace. But for some reason, best practices around that are very rarely applied to age or generation.|||但这很轻松。这就是那些真正有害的刻板印象、偏见和歧视在双向产生的地方。这不是一个单向的问题。不幸的是，这是一个多代际的问题。好吧，让我们谈谈职场。拥有多代际职场有哪些最好的好处？因此，最迷人、真正推动我工作的是，我们所讨论的是一种思想、视角和经验的多样性。因此，我们对职场中各种多样性的力量和益处了解很多。但出于某种原因，围绕这一点的最佳实践很少应用于年龄或代际。
That's a fascinating fact. In our book, we found that 8% of organizations include age and their diversity and inclusion strategies, which is a very low number. And a lot of those are just, well, we put it on the list with everything else we could think of rather than an actual proactive approach. So I think when it comes to age, we really feel more comfortable with people like ourselves. And I think when we're challenged to work across those different generations, we sometimes get stuck in the frustration. The benefit is if you think about a five-generation workplace, so as you said, silent through Gen Z potentially in some industries, we have all of that.
That's a fascinating fact. In our book, we found that 8% of organizations include age and their diversity and inclusion strategies, which is a very low number. And a lot of those are just, well, we put it on the list with everything else we could think of rather than an actual proactive approach. So I think when it comes to age, we really feel more comfortable with people like ourselves. And I think when we're challenged to work across those different generations, we sometimes get stuck in the frustration. The benefit is if you think about a five-generation workplace, so as you said, silent through Gen Z potentially in some industries, we have all of that.|||这是一个令人着迷的事实。在我们的书中，我们发现只有8%的组织将年龄纳入其多元化和包容性战略中，这是一个非常低的数字。其中许多组织只是将其与其他能想到的所有事情一起列在清单上，而不是采取真正积极主动的方法。所以我认为，当涉及到年龄时，我们确实对像自己这样的人感到更舒服。而且我认为，当我们面临跨越这些不同代际进行工作的挑战时，我们有时会陷入挫败感中。好处是，如果你想想一个五代同堂的职场——正如你所说，从沉默的一代到Z世代，在某些行业中可能同时存在——我们拥有这一切。
We've never had that before because people are living and working longer. We have this sitting in front of us. Who wouldn't want to be able to tap into five to six decades of experience, perspective, and different kinds of expertise. So you learn different things depending the time in which you start your life and your career. There are certain skills necessary now. My son's 18.
We've never had that before because people are living and working longer. We have this sitting in front of us. Who wouldn't want to be able to tap into five to six decades of experience, perspective, and different kinds of expertise. So you learn different things depending the time in which you start your life and your career. There are certain skills necessary now. My son's 18.|||我们以前从未有过这种情况，因为人们的寿命更长，工作时间也更长。这种情况现在就摆在我们面前。谁会不想能够利用五到六十年的经验、视角和各种专业知识呢？因此，根据你开始生活和职业生涯的时间，你会学到不同的东西。现在需要某些特定的技能。我儿子18岁了。
So he has to learn a different set of tools and skills than I had to learn at 18. And that's a very powerful kind of diversity of thought and expertise and perspective if we're willing to leverage it. So those are the benefits. We have access to greater information network. So where we look for information, how we find information varies across generations.
So he has to learn a different set of tools and skills than I had to learn at 18. And that-s a very powerful kind of diversity of thought and expertise and perspective if we're willing to leverage it. So those are the benefits. We have access to greater information network. So where we look for information, how we find information varies across generations.|||所以他必须学习一套与我18岁时不得不学习的不同的工具和技能。如果我们愿意加以利用，这是一种非常强大的思想、专业知识和视角的 diversité（多样性）。所以这些就是好处。我们可以接触到更广泛的信息网络。因此，我们去哪里寻找信息以及如何找到信息因代际而异。
Complementary strengths. So there are, as we looked into this in our book as well, different kinds of knowledge. There's things like we didn't come up with this, but we found this very fascinating. Think about know-how versus know-what versus know whom or know when. Those are really interesting ways to acknowledge that I as a 22-year-old, I'm not 22. But if I was, perhaps I would know the new approach, the new tool, the new tech, but maybe I as a 47-year-old might know who we need to talk to to make sure we get buy-in for that. Or when's the right time to launch that initiative, probably not at year end when we're out of budget. So there's an opportunity for complementary knowledge and expertise if we step away from this sort of threat-based scarcity approach where if you're getting an opportunity or air-time,
Complementary strengths. So there are, as we looked into this in our book as well, different kinds of knowledge. There's things like we didn't come up with this, but we found this very fascinating. Think about know-how versus know-what versus know whom or know when. Those are really interesting ways to acknowledge that I as a 22-year-old, I'm not 22. But if I was, perhaps I would know the new approach, the new tool, the new tech, but maybe I as a 47-year-old might know who we need to talk to to make sure we get buy-in for that. Or when's the right time to launch that initiative, probably not at year end when we're out of budget. So there's an opportunity for complementary knowledge and expertise if we step away from this sort of threat-based scarcity approach where if you're getting an opportunity or air-time,|||互补的优势。正如我们在书中探讨的那样，存在着不同类型的知识。比如有些东西——虽然不是我们发明的，但我们觉得非常迷人。想想“知道如何做”（know-how）与“知道是什么”（know-what），以及“知道找谁”（know whom）或“知道何时”（know when）。这些是非常有趣的方式，让我们承认我作为一个22岁的人——我其实不是22岁，但如果我是的话——也许我会知道新的方法、新的工具、新的技术；但也许我作为一个47岁的人，会知道我们需要和谁谈话，以确保我们能获得对该方案的支持。或者什么时候是推出该倡议的最佳时机，大概不是在预算耗尽的年底。因此，如果我们抛弃这种基于威胁的稀缺性思维模式——即如果你得到了机会或发言时间、
or attention that somehow I'm losing. And that tug of war is unfortunately really common and really unproductive. We do a fair amount of public opinion polling at the American Psychological Association, and our pollsters have recommended that we not group people into generations anymore. Are there situations where it's not useful to categorize people as belonging to a particular generation? I love this question. I have a definite opinion on this. I read. I read. I read. I read these every couple months. There's a really well-written piece that comes out on this topic. You know, let's get rid of generations. So my position on this is I think when people say we shouldn't group people by generations, we shouldn't have generations, what they're really saying
or attention that somehow I'm losing. And that tug of war is unfortunately really common and really unproductive. We do a fair amount of public opinion polling at the American Psychological Association, and our pollsters have recommended that we not group people into generations anymore. Are there situations where it's not useful to categorize people as belonging to a particular generation? I love this question. I have a definite opinion on this. I read. I read. I read. I read these every couple months. There's a really well-written piece that comes out on this topic. You know, let's get rid of generations. So my position on this is I think when people say we shouldn't group people by generations, we shouldn't have generations, what they're really saying|||或者注意力，就好像我在失去什么一样——那么就会有获得互补知识和专业知识的机会。这种拉锯战不幸的是非常普遍且毫无成效的。我们在美国心理学协会做了相当多的民意调查，我们的民意调查员建议我们不要再把人们按代际进行分组了。有没有什么情况下，将人们归类为属于特定代际是没有用的？我喜欢这个问题。对此我有明确的看法。我读过。我读过。我读过。我每隔几个月就会读到这些。关于这个主题会发表一篇写得很好的文章。你知道的，让我们抛弃代际吧。所以我对此的立场是，我认为当人们说我们不应该按代际对人进行分组、我们不应该划分代际时，他们真正想说的是
is we need to stop using generational stereotypes, which I absolutely 100% agree with. You cannot tell who someone is by knowing the year they're born. That's a horoscope. That's not psychology. that's not science, that's not research, that's not what we're doing here. My concern when we say, let's get rid of generations. So generations are a social construction, which means we created them to help us understand some form of difference, just like a political party is an example I use a lot. We made that up to say, well, there's this category and this category. It's better to not have generational categories at all than to use stereotypes or bias. So to that degree, I'm on board. But I actually think getting rid of the generational lens altogether results in us losing something
is we need to stop using generational stereotypes, which I absolutely 100% agree with. You cannot tell who someone is by knowing the year they're born. That's a horoscope. That's not psychology. that's not science, that's not research, that's not what we're doing here. My concern when we say, let's get rid of generations. So generations are a social construction, which means we created them to help us understand some form of difference, just like a political party is an example I use a lot. We made that up to say, well, there's this category and this category. It's better to not have generational categories at all than to use stereotypes or bias. So to that degree, I'm on board. But I actually think getting rid of the generational lens altogether results in us losing something|||我们需要停止使用代际刻板印象，对此我百分之百赞同。你无法通过一个人出生的年份来判断他是一个什么样的人。那是星座运势，而不是心理学，不是科学，不是研究，也不是我们在这里所做的事情。当我听到“让我们抛弃代际”时，我的担忧是这样的：代际是一种社会建构，这意味着我们创造了它们来帮助我们理解某种形式的差异，就像我经常举的政党这个例子一样。我们凭空捏造出这个概念来表示，哦，有这个类别和那个类别。与其使用刻板印象或偏见，倒不如完全没有代际类别。所以在某种程度上，我是支持这一点的。但我实际上认为，完全抛弃代际视角会导致我们失去一些
really fascinating and important. Because it's similar to, and I always am careful of how I said this, but it's similar to saying we should be colorblind. Being colorblind is far better than being biased or prejudice, but then you're in some ways ignoring the reality that there's very valuable differences in perspectives by appreciating that layer of someone's identity. So where I like to sit on this is I like to say generational identity is one layer of who we are. And we can put with that age, so your age is different than your generation connected, but different. Your gender, your race, your ethnicity, where you sit in the world, your socioeconomic
really fascinating and important. Because it's similar to, and I always am careful of how I said this, but it's similar to saying we should be colorblind. Being colorblind is far better than being biased or prejudice, but then you're in some ways ignoring the reality that there's very valuable differences in perspectives by appreciating that layer of someone's identity. So where I like to sit on this is I like to say generational identity is one layer of who we are. And we can put with that age, so your age is different than your generation connected, but different. Your gender, your race, your ethnicity, where you sit in the world, your socioeconomic|||非常迷人且重要的东西。因为这类似于——我总是很小心我该如何表达这一点——但这类似于说我们应该是“色盲”（不分肤色）。“色盲”远比带有偏见或歧视要好得多，但从某种意义上说，通过欣赏一个人身份的那个层面，你却忽视了这样一个现实：不同视角之间存在着非常宝贵的差异。所以我喜欢持有的观点是：代际认同是我们身份的一个层面。我们可以把年龄与它结合起来——所以你的年龄不同于你的代际，它们有联系但又不同。还有你的性别、你的种族、你的族裔、你所处的世界、你的社会经济
status, we can add anything we want on there. And that creates this wonderful, complex understanding of someone's view and experience. And if we get rid of generation and say, well, generational differences aren't real, I don't know a single person who has a job who would agree with that statement. But when we look at research, we see a lot, this is interesting, Kim, because we see a lot of research that says, I'm an academic at heart. So we see a lot of generational research that says generational differences mean nothing. They're overblown. We're not finding anything.
status, we can add anything we want on there. And that creates this wonderful, complex understanding of someone's view and experience. And if we get rid of generation and say, well, generational differences aren't real, I don't know a single person who has a job who would agree with that statement. But when we look at research, we see a lot, this is interesting, Kim, because we see a lot of research that says, I'm an academic at heart. So we see a lot of generational research that says generational differences mean nothing. They're overblown. We're not finding anything.|||地位，我们可以在上面添加任何我们想要的东西。这就创造了一种对某人观点和经历的奇妙而复杂的理解。如果我们抛弃代际，说“嗯，代际差异不是真实的”，我不认识任何一个有工作的人会同意这种说法。但当我们看研究时，金，我们会看到很多有趣的东西，因为我们看到了大量研究表明——我本质上是一个学者——我们看到了很多代际研究说代际差异毫无意义。它们被夸大了。我们什么也没发现。
And so it would be very easy to then conclude it's much ado about nothing. We need to stop talking about it. It's not productive. What we're missing when we just look at that tiny piece is that people across generations have very similar intrinsic needs. So whether you're 20 or 60 or 40, or 40 or anywhere in between. We all need respect. We all need connection. We want to be seen as competent. We all need autonomy. So that's rooted deeply in a lot of psychology theories, things like
And so it would be very easy to then conclude it's much ado about nothing. We need to stop talking about it. It's not productive. What we're missing when we just look at that tiny piece is that people across generations have very similar intrinsic needs. So whether you're 20 or 60 or 40, or 40 or anywhere in between. We all need respect. We all need connection. We want to be seen as competent. We all need autonomy. So that's rooted deeply in a lot of psychology theories, things like|||因此，人们很容易得出结论，认为这是小题大做。我们需要停止谈论它。这是没有成效的。当我们只看那小部分时，我们所忽视的是，不同代际的人有着非常相似的内在需求。所以无论你是20岁、60岁、40岁，还是介于两者之间的任何年龄。我们都需要尊重。我们都需要联系。我们希望被视为有能力的。我们都需要自主权。所以这深深根植于许多心理学理论中，比如
self-determination. And we can we could come up with 10 different theories that all agree, the research agrees. We have similar intrinsic needs as humans, no matter how old we are. If we stop there, then we can easily say, so let's just stop talking about generations. But then what we miss is while our needs are the same, the norms we learn as part of a common age group are quite different based on what's going on in the world, the parenting philosophies, what's being emphasized. So the norms you learn about how do you earn respect, for example, are quite different, or what does it mean to connect with someone? So my favorite example on this would be, my dad is 75. He's a very proud baby boomer. He's a retired attorney.
self-determination. And we can we could come up with 10 different theories that all agree, the research agrees. We have similar intrinsic needs as humans, no matter how old we are. If we stop there, then we can easily say, so let's just stop talking about generations. But then what we miss is while our needs are the same, the norms we learn as part of a common age group are quite different based on what's going on in the world, the parenting philosophies, what's being emphasized. So the norms you learn about how do you earn respect, for example, are quite different, or what does it mean to connect with someone? So my favorite example on this would be, my dad is 75. He's a very proud baby boomer. He's a retired attorney.|||自我决定论。我们可以提出10种不同的理论，它们都一致认为，研究也一致认为：作为人类，无论我们多大年纪，我们都有相似的内在需求。如果我们到此为止，那么我们很容易说：好吧，那就别再谈论代际了。但随后我们所忽视的是，虽然我们的需求是一样的，但作为共同年龄群体的一部分，我们所学到的规范却大不相同，这取决于世界上正在发生的事情、育儿哲学以及正在被强调的东西。因此，你所学到的关于如何赢得尊重等规范是截然不同的，或者说与某人建立联系意味着什么。所以我最喜欢的例子是：我父亲75岁。他是一个非常骄傲的婴儿潮一代。他是一名退休律师。
And when our book came out, he said, you know, I don't understand something. Maybe you could explain it to me. He said, when I was starting my career, the way you got respect is you put your head down, you closed your mouth, and you did your job, and you waited for somebody to come tell you, it was time for your promotion. You had earned that promotion. You had earned that race. And he said, by the time I retired, these young people, I always say that's capitalized.
And when our book came out, he said, you know, I don't understand something. Maybe you could explain it to me. He said, when I was starting my career, the way you got respect is you put your head down, you closed your mouth, and you did your job, and you waited for somebody to come tell you, it was time for your promotion. You had earned that promotion. You had earned that race. And he said, by the time I retired, these young people, I always say that's capitalized.|||当我们的书出版时，他说：“你知道吗，我有些事情不太明白。也许你能向我解释一下。”他说：“当我开始职业生涯时，获得尊重的方式是埋头苦干、闭上嘴巴、做好你的工作，然后等待别人来告诉你，是时候晋升了。你赢得了那个晋升。你赢得了那场竞赛。”他说，到了我退休的时候，这些年轻人——我总是说那是大写的，
Like, here comes a stereotype. These young people. were coming to me to tell me it was time for their promotion, and I don't get that. That doesn't make any sense to me at all. That's where entitlement comes from, that perspective. And I thought, this is really important. This is what my work is meant to help people understand, is that in both cases, that person was trying to earn respect.
Like, here comes a stereotype. These young people. were coming to me to tell me it was time for their promotion, and I don't get that. That doesn't make any sense to me at all. That's where entitlement comes from, that perspective. And I thought, this is really important. This is what my work is meant to help people understand, is that in both cases, that person was trying to earn respect.|||就像，刻板印象来了——这些年轻人来找我，告诉我该轮到他们晋升了，我不明白这一点。这对我来说毫无意义。这种特权感就是从那种视角产生的。我想，这非常重要。这就是我的工作旨在帮助人们理解的事情：在这两种情况下，那个人都在试图赢得尊重。
They were trying to prove themselves. For my dad and for many people in his generation, the norm on how you did that was head down, mouth shut, work. They'll come find you when it's your turn. Fast forward to, this would have been the millennial generation probably that he was speaking about. The norm they learned was if you want a spot, you get up to the front of the line and raise your hand and tell everyone you wanted and you're ready because everybody else wants it too and you're not going to get picked if you don't get up there in front and fight for it. So the need is the same. The norm is different. And what we're
They were trying to prove themselves. For my dad and for many people in his generation, the norm on how you did that was head down, mouth shut, work. They'll come find you when it's your turn. Fast forward to, this would have been the millennial generation probably that he was speaking about. The norm they learned was if you want a spot, you get up to the front of the line and raise your hand and tell everyone you wanted and you're ready because everybody else wants it too and you're not going to get picked if you don't get up there in front and fight for it. So the need is the same. The norm is different. And what we're|||他们都在试图证明自己。对于我父亲和他的许多同龄人来说，如何做到这一点的常态是：埋头、闭嘴、工作。轮到你时他们会来找你的。快进到——这大概是他所说的千禧一代。他们学到的常态是：如果你想要一个名额，你就走到队伍最前面，举起手来，告诉所有人你想要并且你已经准备好了，因为其他人也想要，如果你不走到前面去争取，你就不会被选中。所以需求是相同的。常态是不同的。而我们正在
reacting to in the workplace are those norm differences that we then judge as entitled or slacker or snowflake or insert whatever generational derogatory term we want. And so that's why I think that's a long answer to say, I don't want to lose the fascinating element of what it means to grow up in a different period of time because we can't get over our urge to stereotype people and stick them in boxes. Those are not, you know, those don't have to be connected things. It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose GoogleFi Wireless.
reacting to in the workplace are those norm differences that we then judge as entitled or slacker or snowflake or insert whatever generational derogatory term we want. And so that's why I think that's a long answer to say, I don't want to lose the fascinating element of what it means to grow up in a different period of time because we can't get over our urge to stereotype people and stick them in boxes. Those are not, you know, those don't have to be connected things. It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose GoogleFi Wireless.|||职场中做出反应的，正是那些规范上的差异，然后我们将其评判为“有特权”、“摸鱼”、“雪花”或者随便插入我们想要的任何代际贬义词。这就是为什么我认为这是一个冗长的回答，意思是：我不想失去在不同时期长大所具有的迷人元素，只因为我们无法克服将人刻板化并贴上标签的冲动。这些并不是——你知道的，这些不一定是相互关联的事情。现在正值盛花期，我的业务正迅速扩展。为了让花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据网速的手机套餐。这就是我选择Google Fi Wireless的原因。
My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore GoogleFi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees, Google FiWireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Let's talk about some real-world situations that some of our listeners might have experienced on their jobs. You published an article in Forbes recently about what older managers need to know
My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore GoogleFi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees, Google FiWireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Let's talk about some real-world situations that some of our listeners might have experienced on their jobs. You published an article in Forbes recently about what older managers need to know|||即使蜂巢嗡嗡作响，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需35美元起。这可是一个不容错过的优惠。立即探索Google Fi Wireless套餐。除税费和政府规费外，Google Fi Wireless在网络高使用率期间不会遭受数据流量降速。让我们来谈谈一些听众可能在工作中经历过的现实情况。您最近在《福布斯》上发表了一篇文章，关于年长管理者需要了解的
about giving feedback to Gen Z employees. How has feedback changed in recent years with the arrival of younger workers? Yes, this is such a great topic. So I published that along with a few other things after hearing from a number of my clients who had just finished year-end performance reviews with some of their youngest employees. And that feedback was falling flat. There was a situation that was frequent was young employees feeling like that feedback was either overly critical, that that organization didn't care about them as a person, that they weren't understood there and the managers overall were saying, what do they mean? What do they mean? We don't care about their development. We just gave them this very extensive feedback. What's going on? And so that
about giving feedback to Gen Z employees. How has feedback changed in recent years with the arrival of younger workers? Yes, this is such a great topic. So I published that along with a few other things after hearing from a number of my clients who had just finished year-end performance reviews with some of their youngest employees. And that feedback was falling flat. There was a situation that was frequent was young employees feeling like that feedback was either overly critical, that that organization didn't care about them as a person, that they weren't understood there and the managers overall were saying, what do they mean? What do they mean? We don't care about their development. We just gave them this very extensive feedback. What's going on? And so that|||关于如何向Z世代员工提供反馈。随着年轻员工的到来，近年来反馈方式发生了怎样的变化？是的，这是一个非常棒的话题。因此，在听到许多客户刚与他们最年轻的员工完成年终绩效考核后，我发表了这篇文章以及其他一些内容。而这种反馈却收效甚微。经常出现的情况是，年轻员工觉得这种反馈要么过于苛刻，要么组织不关心他们作为个人的感受，他们在那里没有被理解；而管理者总的来说却在说：“他们是什么意思？他们是什么意思？我们不关心他们的发展吗？我们刚刚给了他们这么详尽的反馈。这到底是怎么回事？”所以
was a great thing to explore. And there's always a context. Like, let's understand. Let's get curious. Curiosity over judgment is a big mantra of intelligence. So if you think about the fact, you can very easily say, oh, those fragile snowflakes can't take criticism. That would be the go to, and I said, let's walk that back and think about it. Here's a generation, couple things, very important, norm-wise. We did not emphasize for Gen Z or younger millennials even that they should receive a lot of tough love and criticism and, you know, tough feedback. We stayed away from that. The philosophy or the norm, parenting norm of the time recently has been, we don't want to damage the self-esteem of children. We've seen that be very detrimental. So we're going to try to correct
was a great thing to explore. And there's always a context. Like, let's understand. Let's get curious. Curiosity over judgment is a big mantra of intelligence. So if you think about the fact, you can very easily say, oh, those fragile snowflakes can't take criticism. That would be the go to, and I said, let's walk that back and think about it. Here's a generation, couple things, very important, norm-wise. We did not emphasize for Gen Z or younger millennials even that they should receive a lot of tough love and criticism and, you know, tough feedback. We stayed away from that. The philosophy or the norm, parenting norm of the time recently has been, we don't want to damage the self-esteem of children. We've seen that be very detrimental. So we're going to try to correct|||这是一个非常值得探讨的好事情。而且总是有其背景的。比如，让我们去理解。让我们保持好奇心。用好奇心取代判断是智慧的一大箴言。所以如果你考虑到这样一个事实，你可以非常轻率地说：“哦，那些脆弱的‘雪花’承受不起批评。”这会是惯性思维，而我说，让我们退一步思考一下。这是一代人，有几件非常重要的事情，在规范方面：我们没有向Z世代甚至更年轻的千禧一代强调他们应该接受大量的严厉之爱、批评以及，你知道的，严厉的反馈。我们避开了这一点。最近时期的哲学或规范、育儿规范一直是：我们不想损害孩子的自尊心。我们已经看到那样做非常有害。所以我们将尝试纠正
some of those mistakes by doing it better. We don't really let our kids fail at a young age. We try very hard to kind of catch and protect and hover and do those things for better for worse. That's a different podcast, I'm sure, where, you know, we get them to adulthood, hopefully, you know, sort of with our hands underneath them, hoping that they can then fly. So some of these young people were getting critical feedback, constructive, critical feedback for maybe the first time. And coming out of COVID, probably even more so because we loosened up on things like, you know, grading standards or attendance policies or things that were in place to set expectations,
some of those mistakes by doing it better. We don't really let our kids fail at a young age. We try very hard to kind of catch and protect and hover and do those things for better for worse. That's a different podcast, I'm sure, where, you know, we get them to adulthood, hopefully, you know, sort of with our hands underneath them, hoping that they can then fly. So some of these young people were getting critical feedback, constructive, critical feedback for maybe the first time. And coming out of COVID, probably even more so because we loosened up on things like, you know, grading standards or attendance policies or things that were in place to set expectations,|||通过做得更好来纠正其中一些错误。我们真的不让我们的孩子在很小的时候就经历失败。我们竭尽全力去接住、保护、盘旋，不管好坏都为他们做这些事。我相信这是另一期播客的主题，你知道的，我们让他们进入成年期，希望，你知道的，有点像用双手托着他们，希望他们随后能够展翅高飞。因此，这些年轻人中的一些人可能是第一次获得批判性的反馈、建设性的批判性反馈。在经历新冠疫情之后，情况可能更是如此，因为我们放松了对诸如评分标准、考勤政策或旨在设定期望的事情的限制，
everything sort of fell by the wayside as we navigated our way through that. So if you have that as your background, and then you go in and you have your very first performance review and your boss does it the way they've always done it, here's what you're doing well, here's what you need to approve on, here are your goals. You're not sure probably how to take that. That's maybe your first experience. And then you've got this misalignment where your boss says, well, of course we want to develop this person.
everything sort of fell by the wayside as we navigated our way through that. So if you have that as your background, and then you go in and you have your very first performance review and your boss does it the way they've always done it, here's what you're doing well, here's what you need to approve on, here are your goals. You're not sure probably how to take that. That's maybe your first experience. And then you've got this misalignment where your boss says, well, of course we want to develop this person.|||在我们度过那段时期时，一切似乎都被抛到了脑后。因此，如果你以这个为背景，然后你进去参加你的第一次绩效考核，而你的老板用他们一贯的方式来做：这是你做得好的地方，这是你需要改进的地方，这些是你的目标。你可能不知道该如何接受这一点。这也许是你的第一次体验。然后你会遇到这种错位：你的老板说：“嗯，我们当然想培养这个人。
We just gave them a performance review. and you have a young person who defines development maybe in a very different way than that. So we're assuming that we all view feedback or development as the same thing, which is usually not the case, generationally speaking. So one of the things that I suggest is thinking about you can continue to give feedback any way you want. I always say you don't have to do anything. But one of the things I suggest is having a meeting before the meeting. So you sit down when someone starts, it's an on-
We just gave them a performance review. and you have a young person who defines development maybe in a very different way than that. So we're assuming that we all view feedback or development as the same thing, which is usually not the case, generationally speaking. So one of the things that I suggest is thinking about you can continue to give feedback any way you want. I always say you don't have to do anything. But one of the things I suggest is having a meeting before the meeting. So you sit down when someone starts, it's an on-|||我们刚刚给了他们绩效考核。”而你有一个年轻人，他对“发展”的定义可能与此截然不同。因此，我们假设我们所有人都将反馈或发展视为同一件事，但从代际来看，通常并非如此。所以我建议的事情之一是考虑你可以继续以任何你想要的方式提供反馈。我总是说你什么都不用做。但我建议的事情之一是在会议之前开个会。所以当有人入职时，你坐下来，这是一个入职——
boarding conversation. This is our feedback process. This is why we do it. This is what you can expect. Do you have experience with feedback? What questions do you have for us? And you're pulling the curtain back. I've been actually working on a piece. I'm hot off the press. I'm sneak preview. It's sort of like what I call the Wizard of Oz. If you could pull the curtain back and say, this is why we do feedback this way. This is what it's going to look like. This is what it's for. five or ten minutes of having a conversation about that before anyone gets any feedback can go a long way with a younger generation. And the reason is this generation grew up getting every explanation and answer they could have possibly wanted in 30 seconds from their phone. So when you and I
boarding conversation. This is our feedback process. This is why we do it. This is what you can expect. Do you have experience with feedback? What questions do you have for us? And you're pulling the curtain back. I've been actually working on a piece. I'm hot off the press. I'm sneak preview. It's sort of like what I call the Wizard of Oz. If you could pull the curtain back and say, this is why we do feedback this way. This is what it's going to look like. This is what it's for. five or ten minutes of having a conversation about that before anyone gets any feedback can go a long way with a younger generation. And the reason is this generation grew up getting every explanation and answer they could have possibly wanted in 30 seconds from their phone. So when you and I|||入职谈话。这是我们的反馈流程。这就是我们为什么要这么做。这是你可以期待的。你有接受反馈的经验吗？你对我们有什么问题吗？这就是在拉开帷幕。我实际上一直在写一篇文章。我是刚出炉的。我是抢先预览。这有点像我所说的《绿野仙踪》。如果你能拉开帷幕说：这就是我们以这种方式进行反馈的原因，这就是它的样子，这就是它的用途。在任何人获得任何反馈之前，花五到十分钟就此进行对话，对于年轻一代来说会大有帮助。原因在于，这一代人在成长过程中，可以在30秒内从手机上获得他们可能想要的每一个解释和答案。所以当你和我
started our career, I'm sure would have loved to know why we do feedback this way and what can I expect. But we didn't really feel like we had the ability to ask for that, that that information wasn't something we were allowed to know. That was above our pay grade. And we really had no way to find out. We just thought, well, I guess I'll wait. And when it's my turn to get fee back, I'll understand why we do it this way. That's not the norm this generation has.
started our career, I'm sure would have loved to know why we do feedback this way and what can I expect. But we didn't really feel like we had the ability to ask for that, that that information wasn't something we were allowed to know. That was above our pay grade. And we really had no way to find out. We just thought, well, I guess I'll wait. And when it's my turn to get fee back, I'll understand why we do it this way. That's not the norm this generation has.|||开始我们的职业生涯时，我确信会很想知道为什么我们要以这种方式进行反馈以及我能期待什么。但我们并不觉得我们有能力去询问这一点，那些信息不是我们被允许知道的。那超出了我们的薪酬级别。而且我们真的没有办法查明。我们只是想：“嗯，我想我还是等著吧。等轮到我获得反馈时，我就会明白为什么我们要这么做。”这不是这一代人拥有的常态。
If they want to know why something is a certain way, they have that answer right next to their fingertips. So going into an organization and having this veiled behind the curtain process that you know, we do it this way because we've always done it this way or because I'm your boss, that's why we do it. That's just not going to work. But my experience with Gen Z has been, if I take five minutes and say, let's talk about why we do it this way. Here's why it's this way. We've really thought about it. This is why we feel it's valuable. Here's why we really believe it works. A majority of the time, I've had no issue with pushback. Oh, got it. Thank you for that. That's very
If they want to know why something is a certain way, they have that answer right next to their fingertips. So going into an organization and having this veiled behind the curtain process that you know, we do it this way because we've always done it this way or because I'm your boss, that's why we do it. That's just not going to work. But my experience with Gen Z has been, if I take five minutes and say, let's talk about why we do it this way. Here's why it's this way. We've really thought about it. This is why we feel it's valuable. Here's why we really believe it works. A majority of the time, I've had no issue with pushback. Oh, got it. Thank you for that. That's very|||如果他们想知道为什么某事是某种方式，他们触手可及就能得到答案。因此，进入一个组织并采用这种遮遮掩掩的“幕后”流程，你知道的，“我们这样做是因为我们一直都是这样做的”或者“因为我是你的老板，所以我们才这样做”，这是行不通的。但我对Z世代的经验是，如果我花五分钟说：“我们来谈谈为什么要以这种方式做。原因如下。我们确实认真考虑过。这就是我们认为它有价值的原因。这就是我们真正相信它有效的原因。”大多数时候，我在遭到推托方面没有任何问题。“哦，明白了。谢谢你。那非常
helpful, let's go ahead and get it done. And I get a lot of managers saying, do we really have to do that? Like, I have to have a meeting about why we do it this way. And I said, you don't have to do anything. You called me. You know, keep doing it the way you're doing it, but how's that working? And so I think just remembering that you probably would have loved five minutes of explanation, but we weren't a generation that really had access to information or explanation. unless someone in power wanted to give it to us, that has not been the reality for Gen Z. And so we just need to think about being willing to share the why. And if you feel defensive and you can't tell them why, then that's a great sign that maybe we need to revisit that process.
helpful, let's go ahead and get it done. And I get a lot of managers saying, do we really have to do that? Like, I have to have a meeting about why we do it this way. And I said, you don't have to do anything. You called me. You know, keep doing it the way you're doing. But how's that working? And so I think just remembering that you probably would have loved five minutes of explanation, but we weren't a generation that really had access to information or explanation. unless someone in power wanted to give it to us, that has not been the reality for Gen Z. And so we just need to think about being willing to share the why. And if you feel defensive and you can't tell them why, then that's a great sign that maybe we need to revisit that process.|||有帮助，我们这就把它搞定。”我有很多管理者说：“我们真的必须那样做吗？就像，我必须开会讨论我们为什么要这样大动干戈吗？”我说：“你什么都不用做。是你打电话给我的。你知道的，继续按你现在的方式做吧。但效果如何呢？”所以我认为只要记住，你可能也会很喜欢五分钟的解释，但我们并不是一个真正能获得信息或解释的世代，除非掌权者愿意施舍给我们。对Z世代来说，现实并非如此。所以我们只需要考虑愿意分享“为什么”。如果你感到防备而且无法告诉他们为什么，那正是一个极好的信号，表明我们可能需要重新审视那个流程。
And is it actually any good if we're not able to explain why we're doing it? I actually come from a tradition where the only feedback you got was negative feedback. And if you didn't get any feedback, you were doing your job well. That didn't work either. Well, and you know what's so interesting, right? It's sharing that with a younger employee, I guarantee they would be shocked. Because that's one of the things we also don't realize is younger generations tend to know their own norms. They grow up, right?
And is it actually any good if we're not able to explain why we're doing it? I actually come from a tradition where the only feedback you got was negative feedback. And if you didn't get any feedback, you were doing your job well. That didn't work either. Well, and you know what's so interesting, right? It's sharing that with a younger employee, I guarantee they would be shocked. Because that's one of the things we also don't realize is younger generations tend to know their own norms. They grow up, right?|||如果我们甚至无法解释我们为什么要这样做，那它真的有什么好处吗？我其实出身于这样一种传统：你得到的唯一反馈就是负面反馈。如果你没有得到任何反馈，说明你工作干得很好。那也行不通。嗯，你知道最有趣的是什么吗？把它分享给年轻员工，我保证他们会大吃一惊。因为这也是我们没有意识到的一点：年轻一代往往只了解他们自己的规范。他们长大，对吧？
They go to school. These are the people I'm always around unless it's my family. There's a lot of culture shock with not realizing, you know, or realizing quickly that people don't all do it the way that makes sense to you. and that we haven't always done it the way you're doing it. So that often, you know, I see time and time again with my own students where they don't realize that, for example, people haven't always gone into, you know, push back on their boss, for example, or, you know, question a decision made by someone in authority. It's not that you're not allowed to do it or that it's wrong to do it, but how would it change your approach if you knew that your boss never. would have gone to their boss and questioned their decision, would you maybe decide to approach it a different way if you realize that your behavior was different than what maybe other people
They go to school. These are the people I'm always around unless it's my family. There's a lot of culture shock with not realizing, you know, or realizing quickly that people don't all do it the way that makes sense to you. and that we haven't always done it the way you're doing it. So that often, you know, I see time and time again with my own students where they don't realize that, for example, people haven't always gone into, you know, push back on their boss, for example, or, you know, question a decision made by someone in authority. It's not that you're not allowed to do it or that it's wrong to do it, but how would it change your approach if you knew that your boss never. would have gone to their boss and questioned their decision, would you maybe decide to approach it a different way if you realize that your behavior was different than what maybe other people|||他们上学。除了我的家人，这些人就是我整天围着转的人。当没有意识到——或者没有迅速意识到——并非所有人都会以对你来说合情合理的方式做事时，会产生很大的文化冲击；并且意识到我们过去并不总是按照你现在做的方式做事。所以这种情况经常发生，你知道的，我在我自己的学生身上一次又一次地看到，他们没有意识到，例如，人们过去并不总是去，你知道的，顶撞他们的老板，或者，你知道的，质疑权威人士做出的决定。这并不是说你不被允许这样做，或者这样做是错的，但如果你知道你的老板绝不会去他们的老板那里质疑他们的决定，这会如何改变你的做法呢？如果你意识到你的行为与其他人可能习惯的行为不同，你也许会决定用另一种方式来处理吗？
were used to? So you see those differences everywhere, very interesting ones. What about the issue of working for someone who is younger than you are? How are the dynamics different when there's a younger boss managing an older employee? And is there any, you have any advice for people on either end of the generational spectrum when it comes to that. Yes. And I think the latest stat I've seen on this, Kim, is 41% of us are working for someone younger than ourselves. So that's a role reversal. There's very deep research on the discomfort we have. It just doesn't quite seem like the way things are supposed to be when someone younger than you is in a higher power position. So it's a little uncomfortable on both sides.
were used to? So you see those differences everywhere, very interesting ones. What about the issue of working for someone who is younger than you are? How are the dynamics different when there's a younger boss managing an older employee? And is there any, you have any advice for people on either end of the generational spectrum when it comes to that. Yes. And I think the latest stat I've seen on this, Kim, is 41% of us are working for someone younger than ourselves. So that's a role reversal. There's very deep research on the discomfort we have. It just doesn't quite seem like the way things are supposed to be when someone younger than you is in a higher power position. So it's a little uncomfortable on both sides.|||因此，你到处都能看到这些差异，非常有趣的差异。关于为比你年轻的人工作这个问题呢？当年轻老板管理年长员工时，动态关系有何不同？对于处于代际光谱两端的任何人，在这方面您有什么建议吗？是的。金，我看到的关于这个的最新统计数据是，我们当中有41%的人在为比自己年轻的人工作. 所以这是一个角色的对调。关于我们感到的不适感，有非常深入的研究。当一个比你年轻的人处于更高的权力位置时，事情似乎就是不太对劲。所以双方都会感到有点不舒服。
So we have a whole chapter on this in our book because it's uncomfortable in both directions. And so there's opportunities and challenges. I think if you're a younger person leading someone older, one of the best pieces of advice I have is to think about what will that older person on your team likely be concerned about? what's going to be making them nervous, uncomfortable, resentful, whatever the attitude is. And again, it's usually fear or threat. Like, I'm threatened that this person younger than me has more power, has bigger title. Even if they don't want it themselves, there's a little bit of either resentment or discomfort. And it goes back to the need that we talked about before, the need everybody wants to feel
So we have a whole chapter on this in our book because it's uncomfortable in both directions. And so there's opportunities and challenges. I think if you're a younger person leading someone older, one of the best pieces of advice I have is to think about what will that older person on your team likely be concerned about? what's going on to be making them nervous, uncomfortable, resentful, whatever the attitude is. And again, it's usually fear or threat. Like, I'm threatened that this person younger than me has more power, has bigger title. Even if they don't want it themselves, there's a little bit of either resentment or discomfort. And it goes back to the need that we talked about before, the need everybody wants to feel|||所以在我们的书中，我们专门有一章来探讨这个问题，因为这在两个方向上都让人感到不舒服。因此，其中既有机遇也有挑战。我认为，如果你是一个领导年长者的年轻人，我给出的最好的建议之一就是：思考你团队中的那个年长者可能会担心什么？是什么让他们感到紧张、不舒服、怨恨，无论那是什么态度。再说一次，这通常是恐惧或威胁。就像，“我感到受到威胁，因为这个比我年轻的人拥有更大的权力、更高的头衔。”即使他们自己并不想要那个职位，也会有一点怨恨或不适。这就回到了我们之前谈到的需求：每个人都希望感到
respected and seen as competent. And so I think it all comes down to mutual respect. And this can happen both ways, older, younger, younger to older, but a younger leader going to an older teammate sitting down and saying, I'm really looking forward to working with you. It has to be authentic, obviously. We'll see through it if it's not. But I'm looking forward to working with you.
respected and seen as competent. And so I think it all comes down to mutual respect. And this can happen both ways, older, younger, younger to older, but a younger leader going to an older teammate sitting down and saying, I'm really looking forward to working with you. It has to be authentic, obviously. We'll see through it if it's not. But I'm looking forward to working with you.|||受到尊重并被视为是有能力的。所以我认为这一切都归结为相互尊重。这可以在两个方向上发生：年长对年轻，年轻对年长；但一个年轻的领导者走到一个年长的队友面前坐下来并说：“我真的很期待与你合作。”显然，这必须是真诚的。如果不是，我们一眼就能看穿。但“我真的很期待与你合作。”
You've had so much experience in this area. I'm positive. There's a lot to learn from your experiences. you know, I'm looking forward to partnering with you can go a long way and someone's defensiveness going down. Oh, that person appreciates me. They understand I have experience. I don't constantly have to be proving that I know a lot or that I have a lot of things to
You've had so much experience in this area. I'm positive. There's a lot to learn from your experiences. you know, I'm looking forward to partnering with you can go a long way and someone's defensiveness going down. Oh, that person appreciates me. They understand I have experience. I don't constantly have to be proving that I know a lot or that I have a lot of things to|||“你在这一领域拥有如此丰富的经验。我确信，从你的经历中有很多东西可以学习。”你知道的，“我期待与你合作”可以大大降低某人的防备心。“噢，那个人欣赏我。他们理解我有经验。我不需要不断地证明我知道很多或者我有很多事情可以……”
offer. But what that requires from a younger leader is enough confidence to go to that person and, you know, put the olive branch out and not feel. like they're saying, I don't know what I'm doing. Can you help me? Or, hey, who knows how I got this job over you? But here we are. You have to be confident enough to know, I earn this position. I deserve this position. I understand this might be uncomfortable for this person. So I want to go show that I do respect them. I value them. I'm hoping we can partner. It doesn't make me less respected. It doesn't make me less valuable or worthy of this job, it should hopefully be mutually beneficial,
offer. But what that requires from a younger leader is enough confidence to go to that person and, you know, put the olive branch out and not feel. like they're saying, I don't know what I'm doing. Can you help me? Or, hey, who knows how I got this job over you? But here we are. You have to be confident enough to know, I earn this position. I deserve this position. I understand this might be uncomfortable for this person. So I want to go show that I do respect them. I value them. I'm hoping we can partner. It doesn't make me less respected. It doesn't make me less valuable or worthy of this job, it should hopefully be mutually beneficial,|||提供。但这要求年轻领导者具备足够的自信，去接近那个人，你知道的，伸出橄榄枝，而不是觉得自己好像在说：“我不知道自己在做什么。你能帮帮我吗？”或者“嘿，谁知道我是怎么打败你得到这份工作的？但既然木已成舟……”你必须足够自信，深知：“我赢得了这个职位。我配得上这个职位。我理解这对外面的这个人来说可能很不舒服。所以我想要去表明我确实尊重他们。我重视他们。我希望我们能合作。”这不会让我变得不那么受尊重。这不会让我变得不那么有价值或不配拥有这份工作，希望这能带来互利共赢，
where now they'll see, I'm not a threat to them. I'm here to learn from them. I hope they'll be interested in learning from me. So I think the opportunity there is to really create that psychological safety of, I want this person to feel like they're respected, they're trusted, that they can add value and that we see that. And also, the challenge. to not get defensive. I think anytime you're trying to justify why you're in charge, you tend to put up a wall yourself and people then question like, well, we weren't wondering if she was competent, but now we are because she seemed really defensive about her role. So I'm a big fan of just being straightforward about the fact that, you know, yes, you have
where now they'll see, I'm not a threat to them. I'm here to learn from them. I hope they'll be interested in learning from me. So I think the opportunity there is to really create that psychological safety of, I want this person to feel like they're respected, they're trusted, that they can add value and that we see that. And also, the challenge. to not get defensive. I think anytime you're trying to justify why you're in charge, you tend to put up a wall yourself and people then question like, well, we weren't wondering if she was competent, but now we are because she seemed really defensive about her role. So I'm a big fan of just being straightforward about the fact that, you know, yes, you have|||现在他们会看到，我对他们不构成威胁。我是来向他们学习的。我希望他们也会对向我学习感兴趣。所以我认为那里的机遇在于真正建立那种心理安全感：我希望这个人感到他们受到尊重、受到信任，他们能够创造价值，并且我们看到了这一点。还有，挑战在于不要产生防备心理。我认为任何时候当你试图为主张自己掌权进行辩解时，你往往自己会树起一堵墙，然后人们就会质疑：“嗯，我们本来没怀疑她是否有能力，但现在我们怀疑了，因为她对自己的角色表现得真的很防备。”所以我非常赞成坦诚面对这样一个事实：你知道的，是的，你有
different expertise than I do and I have different expertise than you. And I think if we're open to learning and teaching each other, it should hopefully be mutually beneficial. I think that's really the case for all generations leading in any direction, but particularly the younger, leading the older. I think people universally, they want to feel respected, and that's the key challenge we have to solve in that dynamic. Let's talk for a minute about intergenerational communication at work. So the Washington Post recently published an interesting interactive quiz called How to Tell Your Real Work Age. And it was all about how different generations have different communication habits at work. These are things like, when is it appropriate to send
different expertise than I do and I have different expertise than you. And I think if we're open to learning and teaching each other, it should hopefully be mutually beneficial. I think that's really the case for all generations leading in any direction, but particularly the younger, leading the older. I think people universally, they want to feel respected, and that's the key challenge we have to solve in that dynamic. Let's talk for a minute about intergenerational communication at work. So the Washington Post recently published an interesting interactive quiz called How to Tell Your Real Work Age. And it was all about how different generations have different communication habits at work. These are things like, when is it appropriate to send|||与我不同的专业知识，而我有与你不同的专业知识。而且我认为，如果我们乐于互相学习和教导，那有望实现互利共赢。我认为这确实适用于所有代际向任何方向的领导，尤其是年轻领导年长。我认为普遍而言，人们都希望感受到被尊重，这是我们在那种动态关系中必须解决的核心挑战。我们花一分钟来谈谈工作中的代际沟通。因此，《华盛顿邮报》最近发表了一个有趣的互动测验，名为《如何判断你的真实工作年龄》（How to Tell Your Real Work Age）。这全关于不同代际在工作中有不同的沟通习惯。这些事情包括，什么时候适合发送
an email versus a Slack message versus a text or even how formal your text message should be? How can workers navigate those waters and make sure that they're avoiding misunderstandings with older or younger colleagues? Yes, I weighed in on that quiz, Kim. I was in an airport lounge. And I remember a lot of the conversation, the reporter was wonderful and a lot of the conversation I kept saying, but I don't think you should stereotype. All Gen Zs don't communicate the same way. I did a lot of that to the point where she's like, noted, yes, we're not saying all, you know, it's really like, it's very nuanced. So we need to make sure. But the tendency, right, we really do want a quiz. We want to know, like, what's my communication style? Is it a, is it a millennial
an email versus a Slack message versus a text or even how formal your text message should be? How can workers navigate those waters and make sure that they're avoiding misunderstandings with older or younger colleagues? Yes, I weighed in on that quiz, Kim. I was in an airport lounge. And I remember a lot of the conversation, the reporter was wonderful and a lot of the conversation I kept saying, but I don't think you should stereotype. All Gen Zs don't communicate the same way. I did a lot of that to the point where she's like, noted, yes, we're not saying all, you know, it's really like, it's very nuanced. So we need to make sure. But the tendency, right, we really do want a quiz. We want to know, like, what's my communication style? Is it a, is it a millennial|||电子邮件与Slack消息或短信，甚至你的短信应该有多正式？员工该如何驾驭这些复杂情况，并确保他们避免与年长或年轻同事产生误解？是的，金，我对那个测验发表了看法。我当时在机场候机室里。我记得很多对话，记者非常棒，在很多对话中我一直说：“但我认为你不应该刻板化。并非所有Z世代的沟通方式都一样。”我做了很多这样的强调，以至于她说：“知道了，是的，我们并不是说所有人，你知道的，这真的很像，非常微妙。”所以我们需要确保。但这种倾向，对吧，我们确实想要一个测验。我们想知道，比如，我的沟通风格是什么？是，是千禧一代的
style or a Gen X style. We have that temptation. That's where that human urge to put people in those boxes is very, very strong. So I had mixed feelings about the quiz, to be honest, but they did a pretty good job with it. I think it comes back to this idea that it's not right or wrong. It's just different. So when we talk about intergenerational communication, for example, a story we found when we were doing our book, we were doing a lot of interviewing, was this great program out at Stanford where they do amazing things with longevity and the Fung Fellowship program is the name of the program out there that partners younger students, so undergraduate students, interested in tech with people who are retired, so older adults, and they partner for sort of a mutually beneficial
style or a Gen X style. We have that temptation. That's where that human urge to put people in those boxes is very, very strong. So I had mixed feelings about the quiz, to be honest, but they did a pretty good job with it. I think it comes back to this idea that it's not right or wrong. It's just different. So when we talk about intergenerational communication, for example, a story we found when we were doing our book, we were doing a lot of interviewing, was this great program out at Stanford where they do amazing things with longevity and the Fung Fellowship program is the name of the program out that partners younger students, so undergraduate students, interested in tech with people who are retired, so older adults, and they partner for sort of a mutually beneficial|||风格还是X世代的风格。我们有那种诱惑。这就是人类把人塞进那些盒子里面的冲动非常非常强烈的地方。说实话，我对这个测验有复杂的情感，但他们做得相当不错。我认为这又回到了这个观点：没有对与错，只有不同。因此，当我们谈论代际沟通时，例如，我们在写书时发现的一个故事——我们进行了大量的采访——是斯坦福大学的一个很棒的项目，他们在长寿方面做着了不起的事情，冯氏学者计划（Fung Fellowship program）是该项目的名字，它将对科技感兴趣的年轻学生（即本科生）与退休人员（即老年人）配对，他们为了某种互利共赢的关系而合作
collaboration around things like the project they told us about was wearable technology. I'm sure they do different kinds of projects. But the idea was that the younger people would develop these ideas and the older people would test them out and give them feedback. But the other benefit was the older adults helping to mentor and teach the younger people about being professional and working on a team and things like that. So there are multiple benefits of this collaboration. But they told us the story about a roadblock they ran into with communication where the younger students were doing a lot of texting of their children. teammates. And the texting was informal. It was happening, you know, after regular business hours, whatever those are these days, but this was before COVID. And sometimes they wouldn't get a response
例如他们告诉我们的那个项目是关于可穿戴技术的，这是一种合作。我确信他们做过各种各样的项目。但这个想法是让年轻人开发这些创意，而年长的人则进行测试并给予反馈。但另一个好处是，年长成年人可以指导和教导年轻人如何变得专业、如何在团队中工作等等。因此，这种合作有多种好处。但他们告诉我们这样一个故事：他们在沟通中遇到了一个障碍，年轻学生给他们的队友发了大量的短信。而且这些短信非常随意。你知道的，这是在正常工作时间之外发生的，不管现在的正常工作时间是什么时候，但这是在新冠疫情之前。有时他们收不到队友关于短信的回复
from their teammates from the text. And that was tricky because the question was like, well, why aren't they responding to me? Like, do they not respect me? Are they not interested in this project? And on the side of the older adults, there was this sort of awkwardness around like texting being too informal for the relationship that they had. And so they weren't necessarily feeling like texting was the way that communication should be done. Like maybe it's an email or a phone call or a face-to-face meeting. So when texts were coming in about work-related things after hours, that was judged as maybe not being appropriate because I text with my phone. friends. I text with my family. I don't want to text with this person. I don't know that well from work. And this seems very informal. And also different norms around whether you respond to a text,
来自队友的短信。这很棘手，因为问题就像是，为什么他们不回复我？难道他们不尊重我吗？他们对这个项目不感兴趣吗？而在年长成年人这边，对于发短信这种对于他们之间的关系来说过于随意的行为，有一种尴尬感。因此，他们不一定觉得发短信应该是沟通的方式。也许应该是一封电子邮件、一个电话或是一次面对面的会议。所以，当非工作时间收到关于工作相关事情的短信时，这可能会被认为是不合适的，因为我用手机和朋友发短信。我用手机和家人发短信。我不想和这个在工作上我不太熟悉的人发短信。这显得非常随意。此外，对于是否回复短信，也有不同的规范，
or do you just read it? And that's a passive piece of information. And okay, I heard that, but we'll talk about it tomorrow. So it's just creating some issues on both sides that they had to sit down and talk about. So I like that example because the question isn't, well, should they text or shouldn't they text? The issue is, how do we have a smarter conversation about it? So I love this, I like to come up with questions, power questions to give people to have smarter intergenerational conversations is always my goal. So what's, instead of judging, oh, they shouldn't text, that's not appropriate, or what's wrong with them? Okay, boomer, why aren't you texting me back? That's not productive. Let's step back and say, can you help me understand when you text me in the evening?
还是说你只是读了一下？那只是一条被动的的信息。好吧，我听到了，但我们明天再谈。因此，这在双方都产生了一些问题，他们必须坐下来谈谈。所以我喜欢这个例子，因为问题不在于，他们到底该不该发短信？问题在于，我们如何就此展开更聪明的对话？所以我很喜欢这一点，我喜欢提出一些有力的问题送给人们，以促进更聪明的代际对话一直是我的目标。所以，与其去评判，哦，他们不应该发短信，那不合适，或者他们有什么毛病？好吧，老古董，你为什么不回我短信？那没有建设性。让我们退一步说，你能帮我理解一下，当你在晚上给我发短信时，
is the goal of that just to send me information, are you looking for a response? And then you listen. You try to listen without judgment. Like get curious. This is odd to me. I don't get it. It's bothering me.
发短信的目的只是为了传达信息，还是你在期待一个回复？然后你倾听。你试着不带评判地去倾听。比如保持好奇心。这对我来说很奇怪。我不理解。这困扰着我。
Whatever it is. Like, I want to gather information. Am I understanding? Like, oh, I don't want to interrupt you by calling you. So I sent a text. Because to younger generations, like a text is less intrusive. You can read it when you have time. You could have your phone off.
无论是什么。就像，我想收集信息。我理解对了吗？比如，哦，我不想打电话打扰你。所以我发了一条短信。因为对于年轻一代来说，发短信不那么具有侵扰性。你有空的时候可以读。你可以把手机关机。
But that might not. be the way I see it if I'm an older person. And so hearing that and thinking, oh, they're trying not to bother me, but they had this information to give me. So they thought this was kind of a low-key way to send it is different than why are they interrupting me when I'm spending time with my family. And what happens then is I can then say, oh, interesting. Well, well, let me give you my perspective on that. Because I'm more used to this. And the reason I prefer that is for this reason. So we're both learning. And then the part we sometimes forget is to say, now let's talk about our mutual norm. Let's decide on a norm that's going to work for this project, this goal, this mission. What can we agree is going to be our shared communication for what we're trying to accomplish? And it's sort of like the feedback meeting. It's like five minutes discussing what's our preferred communication channel going to be. My students bless them. every year come to meet him with something like,
但这可能不是我作为一个年长者的看法。所以听到这个并心想，哦，他们尽量不打扰我，但他们有这些信息要告诉我。所以他们认为这是一种低调的发送方式，这与为什么当我和家人在一起时他们要打扰我有很大不同。然后发生的事情是，我可以说，哦，真有趣。好吧，让我告诉你我对这事的看法。因为我更习惯这样。我之所以更喜欢这样，原因在于这个。所以我们都在学习。然后我们有时会忘记的一个部分是说，现在我们来谈谈我们的共同规范。让我们决定一个适合这个项目、这个目标、这个使命的规范。对于我们试图实现的目标，我们可以就什么作为我们共同的沟通方式达成一致？这有点像反馈会议。就像花五分钟讨论我们首选的沟通渠道将是什么。我的学生们，真感谢他们，每年开会都会带来一些像
we did Slack, we did group me, we did this thing. And I'm always like, sure, show me how to use that. And then eventually we have to admit that like everybody's not using it. So what's the point and what are we going to do? So it's about shared negotiation of norms rather than are we going to do it the way we've always done it or do we all really have to do it this new way? It's what is best for the project or best for the goal, probably again, a little bit of both.
我们用了Slack，我们用了GroupMe，我们用了这个东西。我总是说，太好了，教教我怎么用。然后最终我们不得不承认，并不是所有人都一直在用它。所以意义何在，我们接下来要做什么？因此，这是关于规范的共同协商，而不是我们要按照我们一直以来的方式做事，或者我们是否真的都必须以这种新方式做事？什么是对项目最好的，或者对目标最好的，可能依然是两者的结合。
A couple of times in our conversation today, you've mentioned COVID, and I have to ask, do you think that remote work as a result of COVID has changed the way the generations interact at work? Yes. And I think there's so much there. I think starting with the fact that one of my favorite intelligence examples is we were, you know, we as a society, we're very sure when lockdown hit that Gen Zs were going to do great and the rest of us were going to struggle. because of it, we thought it was tech, right? Well, they're going to figure it. They're fine being online. The rest of us are in trouble. And we were 180 degrees off on that. So all the data that came out the months after, you know, lockdown started,
在我们今天的对话中，你几次提到了新冠疫情，我不得不问，你认为新冠疫情导致的远程工作是否改变了代际在工作中的互动方式？是的。我认为这其中包含了很多东西。我想从这样一个事实开始：我最喜欢的关于“聪明”的例子之一是，我们，你知道的，我们作为一个社会，在封锁开始时非常确定，Z世代会做得很好，而我们其余的人会挣扎。因为这个，我们以为这是技术问题，对吧？好吧，他们会搞定的。他们在线上过得很好。我们其余的人有麻烦了。而我们在这一点上完全背道而驰。所以在封锁开始后的几个月里出现的所有数据，
Gen Z was reporting the lowest levels of satisfaction, the highest levels of struggle with working from home, followed by millennials, then Gen X, then baby boomers. And it was a great, like, plot twist moment. It's like, what? That's not what we thought was going to happen, which is why I love Gen Intelligence, because if you took a few minutes, once we all did the learning curve on Zoom and all the other things we had to sort out, the things that matter most and are most important during the early stages of your career. So you can't separate generation and career stage.
Z世代报告的满意度最低，在家工作的挣扎程度最高，其次是千禧一代，然后是X世代，最后是婴儿潮一代。这是一个巨大的、戏剧性的情节转折时刻。就像，什么？这跟我们预想的完全不一样，这也是为什么我喜欢代际智慧的原因，因为如果你花几分钟时间，一旦我们都在Zoom和其他所有需要理清的事情上度过了学习曲线，那些在你的职业生涯早期最重要、最关键的事情就会浮现。所以你不能把代际和职业阶段分开。
Those are intermingled are things that are very hard to accomplish remotely. So we focused a lot on just working remotely hurting productivity. Well, no, most of us, depending on the job, can be productive at home. But if I'm 25 or 24 and I've just been on the job a short amount of time, what are my concerns? What are my needs? Well, I want to prove myself to my boss. I want to make a good impression. I have a lot of things I'm learning that are brand new.
这些是交织在一起的，而在远程工作环境下很难实现。因此，我们把很多注意力集中在远程工作损害生产力上。好吧，不，我们大多数人，取决于工作性质，都可以在家里保持高效率。但如果我25岁或24岁，并且刚刚工作了一小段时间，我的顾虑是什么？我的需求是什么？好吧，我想向我的老板证明自己。我想留下好印象。我有很多全新的东西正在学习。
I'm trying to establish my professional network. I want to meet my coworkers. I want to go have coffee or go have a drink after work. All the things that you do when you start a new job, you couldn't do any of that. All of the things that are about establishing yourself as a professional person were gone. The idea of putting on actual clothes and getting on a train or driving into the city or all the, you know, whatever you had in your head is I'm going to start my life and my career. You're in your parents' basement in your sweatpants. and suddenly you're also a professional.
我正在努力建立我的职业网络。我想见见我的同事。我想去喝杯咖啡，或者下班后去喝一杯。所有你在开始一份新工作时会做的事情，你一件都做不了。所有关于将自己确立为专业人士的事情都消失了。穿上真正的衣服，坐上火车或开车进城的想法，或者你在脑海中拥有的任何关于“我要开始我的生活和职业生涯”的想法都不复存在。你穿着运动裤待在父母的地下室里，突然之间你也是个专业人士了。
So I'm seeing a lot of fallout from that a couple years out. And when we say, well, Gen Z doesn't want to work, or Gen Z is quiet quitting, or Gen Z is leaving after six months, well, of course they are. I have former students I stay in contact with who say, I love the flexibility of working remote or hybrid, but I've actually never met my boss in person. Or I go into the office and there's three people in there. none of them are on my team, and it's weird. Right. So I think we shouldn't be surprised that we're having challenges with things like organizational commitment, satisfaction, more trouble with things like, quote, loyalty than we
所以几年后我看到了很多这方面的后果。当我们说，Z世代不想工作，或者Z世代在悄悄离职，或者Z世代在六个月后离职，好吧，他们当然会这样。我有一些保持联系的前学生说，我喜欢远程或混合办公的灵活性，但我实际上从未亲自见过我的老板。或者我去办公室，里面只有三个人，他们都不是我团队的，这感觉很怪。对。所以我认为，我们在面对诸如组织承诺、满意度等问题遇到挑战时，不应该感到惊讶，我们在诸如所谓的“忠诚度”方面遇到了更多麻烦，甚至超过了
even had in our last generation, because we're not doing any of the things that build connection or belonging in organizations very well. And yet, in this new hybrid world. So I think generationally, I get the question a lot. Do gen Zs want to come into the office? And it's like, well, again, we're talking about millions of people. My belief anecdotally and also I've seen some trends on this is everybody wants flexibility. It goes back to that intrinsic need of autonomy.
在我们上一代人中也是如此，因为我们并没有把任何能在组织中建立连接或归属感的事情做好。然而，在这个新的混合世界里。所以我认为在代际上，我经常被问到一个问题。Z世代想来办公室吗？答案是，好吧，同样，我们在谈论数百万的人。我的直观信念以及我也看到的一些趋势是，每个人都想要灵活性。这可以追溯到自主性的内在需求。
But flexibility means something different depending on your life stage and you know, I love working from home because I can let my dogs out and I can. check on my parents and I can, you know, go pick up my kid and I already know how to do my job and I have a network and I just get a lot more done here until I need to go into my office for certain things, which I know what those things are. Not worried about impressing anybody, at least, you know, for the time being. So my needs are different than, you know, a 23 year old who's starting to establish herself. And so what I need in terms of flexibility is different. And I think the last thing I'll say about it is also if I started my career going into the office five days a week, 10 hours a day, then when my employer says, we're going to embrace flexible work, Megan, you only have to come in three days a week. I'm going to think that sounds amazing. I only have to come in three days a week. That is so flexible. If I started my career during COVID and never had to come in at all, and now suddenly I'm supposed to come in three days a week. So now there's a
但灵活性根据你的人生阶段意味着不同的东西，你知道的，我喜欢在家工作，因为我可以让我的狗出去，我可以照看我的父母，我可以，你知道的，去接我的孩子，而且我已经知道如何做好我的工作，我有一个网络，我在这里可以完成更多的工作，直到我需要去办公室处理某些事情，我知道那些事情是什么。至少在目前，我不担心给任何人留下深刻印象。所以我的需求与开始确立自己的23岁年轻人不同。因此，我在灵活性方面的需求是不同的。我想我要说的最后一件事是，如果我的职业生涯是从每周去办公室五天、每天10小时开始的，那么当我的雇主说，我们将拥抱弹性工作，梅根，你只需要一周来三天。我会觉得这听起来太棒了。我一周只需要来三天。这太灵活了。如果我的职业生涯是在新冠疫情期间开始的，根本不需要来公司，而现在突然要求我一周来三天。所以现在有了
commute and I got to live closer to my office and I got to find somebody to watch my dog. Like now suddenly that doesn't seem flexible at all. There's a contrast effect, I think, that we're forgetting as well. So my last question, I'm going to ask you to do a little prognostication. How do you think Gen Z is going to change the office culture going forward? I love Gen Z. I should say that. I love all generations, but I'm fascinated. I think we keep talking about them like they're coming. And I had someone at one of my last keynotes say, could you tell people we're already here, which I thought was great, because the oldest Gen Zs, I think, are going to be 27 this year. So we have like almost 10 years of Gen Zs in the workplace.
通勤，我得住得离办公室近一点，我得找个人帮我照看狗。就像现在这样，这突然一点也不灵活了。我认为还有一个对比效应，我们也被忽略了。所以我的最后一个问题，我要请你做一个简单的预测。你认为Z世代将如何改变未来的办公室文化？我喜欢Z世代。我应该这么说。我喜欢所有代际，但我对此很着迷。我认为我们一直谈论他们，就好像他们正在到来一样。我在我的最后一次主题演讲中听到有人说，你能告诉大家我们已经在这里了吗，我觉得这很棒，因为最年长的Z世代，我想，今年将是27岁。所以我们在职场中几乎有10年的Z世代了。
I think Gen Zs are people who as a whole, their norm has been that they have gotten to do a lot of choose your own adventure. And what I mean by that is they've gotten to grow up curating their media, their news, their playlists, that they've been able to customize and individualize things in a way that's really fantastic. I'm seeing them do that with higher ed. So we're watching really carefully that it might not be a four-year degree because not everybody wants or needs a four-year degree. We told people in my generation, in the millennial generation that you absolutely at minimum had to get a four-year degree. And now we've got a lot of people with a lot of loan debt and not a good job.
我认为Z世代作为一个整体，他们的常态一直是他们能够做很多“选择你自己的冒险”。我的意思是，他们在大肆策划自己的媒体、新闻、播放列表的过程中长大，他们能够以一种非常棒的方式定制和个人化事物。我看到他们在高等教育中也在这样做。所以我们正在非常仔细地观察，它可能不是一个四年制学位，因为不是每个人都想要或需要一个四年制学位。我们在我这一代人、在千禧一代中告诉人们，你绝对至少要获得一个四年制学位。现在我们有很多人背负着大量的贷款债务，却没有一份好工作。
And so Gen Zs are looking and saying, well, I don't know that that's necessarily true. Meeting with, now there's certification programs. Now there's, you know, upskilling, there's trade schools. There's all of these paths. And like my son being 18, we're seeing skilled trades, for example, have a very high. I mean age because we didn't encourage the last two generations to go into the skilled trades. So there's a huge pipeline gap. We have a huge need.
因此，Z世代正在审视并表示，我不认为这一定是真的。与现在有认证项目相遇。现在有，你知道的，技能提升，有贸易学校。有所有这些途径。就像我18岁的儿子一样，我们看到熟练技工，例如，有非常高的需求。我的意思是年龄，因为我们没有鼓励过去两代人去从事熟练技工工作。所以这里有一个巨大的管道缺口。我们有巨大的需求。
My husband's a contractor and a carpenter, and he's often the youngest person on a job site. So there's so many opportunities there that we're now seeing younger people go to trade school again, apprentice again, taking on less debt, but going directly to get practical experience in places where there's a lot of demand. So the thing I love about Gen Z, it's frightening for higher ed, which is important because, you know, I work there. But I also love that they don't necessarily have the exact same pressure to do it the way everybody else was told they had to do it. And I think COVID has really, for better, for worse, created a blank slate. The idea of taking a gap year, which is very European, but very brilliant. Do we really think 18-year-olds or 17-year-olds know what they want to do for the rest of their life and we should force them to pick right now? Probably not. Like a year or two to
我丈夫是一名承包商和木匠，他经常是工作现场最年轻的人。所以这里有这么多的机会，我们现在看到年轻人重新去读技校，重新去做学徒，承担更少的债务，而是直接去有大量需求的地方获取实践经验。所以我喜欢Z世代的地方在于，这对高等教育来说是可怕的，这很重要，因为，你知道的，我在那里工作。但我也喜欢他们不一定非要承受和别人被告知必须做的一模一样的压力。我认为新冠疫情确实，不管是好是坏，创造了一张白纸。间隔年的想法，这非常欧洲化，但也非常棒。我们真的认为18岁或17岁的人知道他们余生想做什么，我们应该强迫他们现在就做出选择吗？可能不会。花一两年时间
figure out who you are and what you want before you start paying college tuition is not a ridiculous idea. So I think they're going to do it on their own terms. I'm seeing really great parallels between Gen X and Gen Z. So the pushback against hustle culture, the pushback. The pushback. against, you know, workaholic tendencies and trying to really take what we learned out of COVID, all of us, that maybe we need more balance. Maybe career shouldn't be everything. That there's a cost to that. I think that's what they're going to do. A couple other short things. I'm loving their ability to speak up for things like wellness and mental health support at work, the first generation that's really broken down the stigma of mental health discussions at work,
在开始支付大学学费之前，弄清楚你是谁以及你想要什么，并不是一个荒谬的想法。所以我认为他们将按照自己的方式去做。我看到X世代和Z世代之间有着非常棒的相似之处。所以对内卷文化的反对，这种反对。反对。你知道的，对工作狂倾向的反对，并试图真正吸取我们所有人从新冠疫情中学到的东西，也许我们需要更多的平衡。也许职业生涯不应该是一切。这样做是有代价的。我认为这就是他们将要做的。另外两件短小的事情。我很喜欢他们敢于为工作中的健康和心理健康支持等事情发声，这是真正打破工作场所心理健康讨论耻辱感的第一代人，
I think they're going to cause us all, are they all right now to figure out how do we respond to that? I get a lot of those questions. I don't know what to say when my Gen Z employee tells me that they're having mental health struggles. It's like, well, that's probably something we need to figure out because they're going to keep talking about it and good for them. And if you're from a generation that was told you can't talk about it at work, there's a learning curve there. We've got to, to figure out what to do. So I think they're going to continue to ask for things that we all would have loved but didn't think we were allowed to want. And that is going to cause challenges and ripples, but I think it's really important progress. Dr. Gerhardt, I want to thank you for talking
我认为他们将促使我们所有人，或者他们现在就在促使我们弄清楚如何对此做出回应？我得到了很多这样的问题。当我的Z世代员工告诉我他们正在经历心理健康挣扎时，我不知道该说什么。这就像，这可能是我们需要弄清楚的事情，因为他们会继续谈论它，这很好。如果你来自一个被告知不能在工作场所谈论它的一代，这里有一个学习曲线。我们必须弄清楚该做什么。所以我认为他们将继续要求我们所有人都想要但认为自己不被允许去追求的东西。这将带来挑战和涟漪，但我认为这是非常重要的进步。Gerhardt博士，我想感谢你今天和我交谈
to me today. It's been really fascinating. I think I learned a lot. Well, thank you for the invitation, Kim. I enjoyed the conversation. You can find previous episodes. of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.w. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对我来说这真的很迷人。我想我学到了很多。好吧，谢谢你的邀请，金。我很享受这次对话。你可以在我们的网站 www.w.w. speakingof psychology.org 上找到《心理学之声》的往期节目，也可以在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。如果你喜欢我们节目的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，你可以给我们发电子邮件：speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学之声》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔迪扬（Chris Condyenne）。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学协会。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。